- Hi, I'm Trystan.
I started bladesmithing
about four years ago--
almost five, actually,
on the 12th.
The 12th will be
my fifth year anniversary,
which is really exciting.
[laughs]
This was my first anvil.
Uh, my bus driver actually
gave it to me.
I have a lot of people
that really support me
in bladesmithing and they think
it's a really cool hobby
that I'm doing.
So my bus driver was like,
"Hey, I have this.
Uh, if you want it,
then it's yours."
It's kind of awesome.
It's like I'm here because of
the community around me.
- Hey, so I'm Mike Deibert,
and here, we're at my shop.
I just want to give you
a little tour,
with the help of Benjamin
and Isaiah.
All right, follow me.
Over here is my pride and joy--
this is Rosie.
Some really awesome people
helped me
to get this power hammer.
When I moved back to the U.S.,
we didn't have a lot of
equipment
for me to continue forging
and these guys took it
upon themself
to raffle off some knives
and voila, look at this.
This is what awesome
friendships create.
And I'm very, very thankful
for it.
- This is a 20-ton
hydraulic press
that my uncle lent me.
It's pretty cool.
You press this button.
[loud rattling]
And it starts pressing,
and then you twist this knob
and it goes back up.
This was actually
an auto body press,
so it's not really designed
for bladesmithing application,
so it doesn't have, like,
the foot pedal or anything
to make it more convenient for
somebody holding hot metal.
So this is kind of like
what I really enjoy doing,
this style of knife.
It's just kind of pretty.
I like the curves of the handle
and all the twists and stuff.
They're pretty functional
pieces too,
but they're just really
more artistic
and I think I like that part
about bladesmithing;
how artistic you can be,
'cause before
I was a bladesmith,
I was more of an artist,
so I would draw a lot
and I used to do pottery
and stuff, painting classes,
just anything that is more
expressive that I can do.
Like, I'm in culinary school
right now as well, so...
I just dabble in the arts.
[laughs]
- These two pieces of equipment
over here--
this 25-ton press
and 25-pound little giant--
these were both equipment
by the late John White,
master bladesmith with
American Bladesmith Society.
He was a true inspiration
to many, many bladesmiths,
including myself.
Unfortunately, about three
years ago he passed away.
To have some of his equipment
in his shop
is a huge, huge deal to me.
Every time I use it, I think
of him and his legacy.
And this is my lovely bride,
Lauren.
Mother of five awesome boys,
and the one who lets me do
what I do in the shop.
I couldn't do any of
this without her.
Thanks, babe.
[chuckles]